Paul kennedy,
welcome to ideas aristotle cleaned
happiness was the ultimate purpose of
knife.
Mathematician and philosopher.
Blaise Pascal,
believe that all men seek happiness.
The poet Alexander Pope enthused,
oh,
happiness.
Our beings end
and
praising.
The virtue of happiness is both timeless
and timely.
Go to your local bookstore and you'll
find shelves packed with titles like the
art of happiness,
authentic happiness,
the how of happiness,
the happiness advantage to name just a
few newspapers and popular magazines
regularly published scientific studies
toting the benefits of happiness.
Happy people enjoy a greater capacity
for intimacy in relationships.
Happiness increases your physical,
mental,
and emotional health.
Happiness makes you more creative
with all that happiness has going for
it.
Who doesn't want more of it as one
expert in the science of happiness?
Put it.
It is the holy grail of life.
Everyone wants happiness.
CBC,
producer,
Frank Fault isn't so sure in this hour
of ideas,
frank questions our culture's obsession
with happiness and wonders.
If it's time to cool or hot pursuit of
it.
Here's his documentary,
say no to happiness.
Let me make one thing perfectly clear.
I am not,
nor have I ever been a curmudgeon,
at least not a committed one.
I like feeling good.
I try to maintain an optimistic outlook,
preferring to walk on the sunny side of
the street,
but am I a happy person to quote the
English poet,
William Blake?
Joy and woe are woven.
Fine.
I can tell you that's more of a mantra
for me.
Then don't worry,
be happy,
but to be fair,
having done some looking into this whole
business around happiness,
I know that no one is suggesting that
striving for happiness is about ignoring
the woes of life and being cheerful.
Twenty four,
seven.
What I do know is that what is meant by
happiness is rather elusive.
Sure.
Aristotle talked about the importance of
happiness,
but what he meant by happiness had to do
with living a life of virtue,
achieving the golden mean,
a life lived balance.
Something like what a surfer achieves
when catching the perfect wave.
The fact is philosophers,
theologians,
and scientists have failed to come up
with a definition of happiness that will
make everyone well happy.
Well,
it's absolutely true that happiness is a
very elusive concept.
I started my career as a lawyer and I.
I spent a semester arguing about the
definition of a contract and happiness
is even more hard to pin down.
There's something like 15 academic
definitions of happiness.
Gretchen Rubin is the author of the
bestseller,
the happiness project in which he
details her year of trying to achieve
greater happiness in her life.
For me,
sort of coming to it as a lay person,
the looseness of the term happiness
wasn't a problem and in fact was sort of
an advantage because it could encompass
a lot of different things and different
people might emphasize different
qualities within happiness.
For some people it's more about peace
and some people meaning some people
satisfaction,
some serenity,
some mindfulness people emphasize
different aspects of it and I really
wish I didn't have to agree with
everyone else and what was really
important for me was not to arrive at
some perfect definition of happiness,
but really to say to myself,
well,
how could I be happier?
Whatever it is to be happy.
What can I do to be happier next week,
next month,
so I sort of took the dodge of justice
potter Stewart who said of obscenity,
I know it when I see it,
and I decided that for me,
I knew what it meant to be happier and I
didn't really have to get all tangled up
in the precise definitions that are
required if you're going to do certain
kinds of examinations of the subject.
Gretchen got the idea to devote a year
to being happier while stuck on a bus in
the pouring rain,
not exactly a situation that inspires
positive moods.
As it turns out,
it afforded her one of those rare
moments for self reflection in which she
wondered what do I want from life
anyway,
and what Gretchen realized that she
wanted was to be happier.
Not that she was unhappy.
She had a good marriage,
two small children she adored and was
completing a book on John F Kennedy.
What I meant by wanting to be happier
was that I.
I felt that I needed to appreciate my
life more.
I felt like time was passing so quickly
and I wanted to grab onto it.
I wanted to appreciate it.
I didn't want to take it for granted.
I have a phrase that I often say to
myself,
the days are long,
but the years are short.
I wanted to ask more of myself.
I wanted to be a better mother.
I wanted to be a wife.
I want to be a better friend and wanted
to be a better writer.
I wanted to be a better citizen.
I wanted to
expect more for myself and I thought
about the qualities that I wanted and
it's,
yeah,
I want it to be more creative and more
lighthearted and more calm and more
patient and have more forbearance and
less be less judgemental,
less naggy,
and I wanted to bring my life more into
harmony with my values and it's funny.
I don't think I really understood that
very well at the beginning.
That was the.
That was one of the major,
major things that I learned as I went on
is that was what was so important was
that my life reflect my values,
my temperament,
my interests,
that I could only build a happy life on
the foundation of my own nature.
Gretchen realized that if she was going
to tackle a project of this size,
she needed a plan,
so she created a chart.
The chart was divided into the 12 months
of the year.
Each month has a theme.
For example,
the theme for January was boost energy.
February.
Remember love March,
aim higher and so on,
and for each month she made a list of
daily resolutions,
so under June's theme of make time for
friendship,
her resolutions were,
remember birthdays,
be generous,
don't gossip,
make new friends.
Every night.
Gretchen would put a checkmark by
resolution indicating that she had
managed to keep it that day.
Having a chart help Gretchen to achieve
or monthly goals,
but seven months into a project,
the pursuit of happiness got stalled.
I hit a low point in my happiness
project at where I felt like I was
making no progress.
I was tired of my way of thinking.
I wasn't tired of the subject of
happiness,
which I have never failed to find
fascinating,
but I was tired of my way of thinking
about it.
You know,
just like every time you go to buy
clothes you buy the same black sweater
that you bought before.
I just felt like my thoughts were stuck
in a groove.
I felt that I was backsliding and all
the usual ways and one of the things is
when you think a lot about how you want
to be better,
it makes you much more aware of what
you're doing wrong.
So for example,
I didn't think I gossip very much,
but when I decided that I was going to
stop altogether,
I realized how often I did.
So I was much more aware of all the
things that I was doing that I knew were
contrary to my happiness.
But I was doing anyway.
And one of the things that came from my
happiness project is I just have this
long bag of things that I do to try to
get through it.
So it's things like go to bed early,
call a friend,
go outside in the sunlight,
gets some exercise,
do a good deed for someone else.
One of the best ways to self medicate.
I did all these things and eventually I
came out of it.
But I think it's natural to just go
through these periods where you just
feel blue.
Um,
and that wasn't for any particular
reason.
But then of course,
naturally we all have periods where for
a very specific reason we're feeling
very unhappy.
So I think one of the things that are
happiness project is sometimes it's not
possible to be happy.
It's just not realistic that you're just
not in a happy time of life.
It's not,
you're not happy.
But I think what I learned was there,
there's things that you can do to try to
be as happy as you can be under the
circumstances.
And that kind of gives you the armor
that you need to deal with a difficult
situation.
Like any smart person planning along
trip,
Gretchen did lots of research and
preparation for her year long journey.
Many of the ideas she used to help her
deal with a difficult times came from
the emerging science of positive
psychology.
Positive psychology is really about the
scientific understanding of what makes a
life worth living,
what are the conditions that lead to
that,
and then most importantly,
what are the strategies that we can use
to help people move a little bit closer
between where they presently are and
where ideally they'd like to be.
Todd Cashton is associate professor of
psychology at George Mason University in
Virginia and author of designing
positive psychology,
a book on the science of wellbeing.
He is also a self described provocateur
and the field of positive psychology.
The more that you actually take a gauge
of how happy you are or assess how happy
you are or think about,
reflect on,
am I happy right now?
The more that you do that,
the less happy you become and it becomes
quickly.
We're talking about four times a day.
You think about,
am I happy?
You're less light.
You're actually show detriments in your
happiness,
and the reason for that is we're leaving
the present moment so no longer are we
in the present and being open and
receptive.
We're constantly deciding is what I'm
feeling or thinking about now fit with
being happy.
There's a lot of well meaning people who
are studying happiness but are not
skeptical.
I don't take things at face value.
I'm a scientist.
I want where's the data?
Where's the evidence?
Mindfulness.
There's this cultural obsession about
taking this philosophical and ancient
teachings about mindfulness,
which is fantastic,
but then the question is,
is it always adaptive to be mindful?
And the answer to as to most absolute
statements is no.
It's very resource intensive to be
mindful,
to focus with great profound awareness
and attention consumes energy.
If you think about emergency medical
technicians going on the scene for
someone for a crime scene or someone,
uh,
that's bloodied and has maybe you know,
hours to potentially live needs to be
brought to a hospital.
There's research to show that being
mindless and reflexively using their
skills to get the job done right then
and there is more adaptive than being
mindful,
so being a provocateur is about bending
over backwards to disprove ideas,
to find out the truth and unravel some
of the mysteries of human nature as
opposed to blindly accepting things on
faith because they fit with what I'd
like things to look like.
What concerns me with a current
obsession with happiness is that under
the rubric of happiness,
all sorts of things that aren't really
related are often discussed.
So for example,
there are claims that happy people are
healthier.
Actually,
the research doesn't precisely indicate
that.
What it indicates is that people who
have less negative emotion are healthier
and we don't exactly know the direction
of causality.
I mean negative emotion is a dimension
in and of itself and people who are high
in negative emotion tend to be depressed
and anxious and depression is associated
with increased production of a stress
hormone.
Cortisol,
and that seems to have very negative
consequences over time.
It impairs your immune system and makes
you more susceptible to obesity and
depression and cancer and heart disease,
but technically that's a negative
emotion issue.
Jordan Peterson as a clinical
psychologist and teaches at the
University of Toronto.
He lectures on topics such as the nature
of self deception,
the role of neuroscience and human
behavior.
The quest for meaning and purpose in
life.
Claim is often made.
The happy people are more creative and
the evidence for that again is very
weak.
There are a few studies that indicate
that if you put people in a state of
positive mood that they can think in a
more creative manner briefly,
but the bulk of the personality evidence
suggests that creative people are
somewhat disagreeable and that they're
high in a trait called openness and
openness is a measure of fluidity of
thought and it appears to be
fundamentally unrelated to happiness.
It might be objected.
I suppose that the right response to
negative situations is to consider how
they might be made better and I would
agree with that,
but the problem is is that making things
better and being happy are not the same
thing.
Unless you decide by definition that
they're the same thing,
in which case I don't believe that
you're speaking within the scientific
realm because you're not allowed to put
vastly differing phenomena in the same
box and called them the same.
If you're a scientist,
you can do that in normal conversation
and so for example,
if someone is suffering from a terrible
illness,
you might determine that aiding them
would be an appropriate thing to do and
you might also consider that that would
make you feel better.
But to call that the pursuit of
happiness is merely to be very unclear
about the distinction between compassion
and joy and given the state of
psychological science at this point.
There's absolutely no excuse for failing
to make that.
But
you see,
I've dodged that by saying my have this
project is my happiness,
and so the fact that there might be
multiple definitions or sub topics live
in happiness that are somehow separable.
I think that you get further in terms of
thinking about how to be happier if you
just throw it all into one big basket.
Rather than trying to tease out the
difference between compassion and
happiness,
of course had been questioned in a
happiness project with you're setting
out to be happier is,
well,
how are you going to know if you're
happy or how are you going to measure
yourself and and I have a friend,
he's a scientist and he was very,
very focused on this.
His idea was as I should have my husband
score me every morning and night on a
level one to 10 scale and I was a look.
That would definitely not add to the
happiness in my household because
there's just no way my husband is going
to be sitting around scoring me morning
and night and I do think that I don't
really think that that was a very
productive exercise to do.
I just didn't approach it very
scientifically.
I said to myself,
I want to be happier.
Whatever that means,
whatever the looseness of the term
happiness and happier mean,
and if I think I'm happier,
I am happier.
And Kevin come to the end of it and
having continued to live with the
consequences of it because.
Because I continue to do all my
resolutions and many,
many more resolutions,
so my happiness project is really
something that I think I'll do for the
rest of my life.
It's just indisputable to me.
Um,
and I think anybody who's around me
would say that I'm absolutely happier.
The atmosphere of my household is let
more lighthearted and more calm.
It seems like we have more time,
but it's not like we're doing anything
less.
It feels more rich,
but also more simple.
I don't have a chart that shows me
ticking upward.
Um,
I don't have vials of blood showing how
my hormone levels have changed,
but I definitely feel confident saying
that I did make myself happy.
Gretchen's quest for happiness inspired
and continues to inspire others to
create their own happiness projects,
which explains why her book has been on
best seller lists since first hitting
the market in 2009.
Gretchen's most important piece of
advice for those wanting to follow her
example is this,
regardless of how you might define
happiness for yourself,
making happiness,
that the primary goal in your life is
going to help you achieve it.
There's a long tradition of people
arguing that you shouldn't aim directly
at happiness and that happiness is
something that's a byproduct of a life
well lived or a life directed at other
aims and that you should and if you aim
at being happy,
he was sort of will forte yourself or
trip over your own feet or or somehow be
pursuing wrong goals that will bring you
to a happy life.
And in my own experience,
I really think that you're much more
likely to hit a target if you aim at it.
And I found for myself that when I said
to myself,
am I happy?
How could I be happier?
I almost instantly did become happier
just because asking myself that question
made me appreciate more of what elements
of happiness I already did have in my
life.
Things that I was taking for granted or
being distracted from.
And it also helped me see places where I
could make changes that were not hard.
It's funny.
Happiness has a surprisingly bad
reputation and I got a lot of criticism
from people when I.
When I was saying that I was doing a
happiness project that I was trying to
make myself happier,
I was talking to a journalist who
clearly explain that this was a very,
very selfish,
complacent,
spoiled,
bratty undertaking,
and he was somebody who spent a lot of
time.
I'm doing kind of foreign reporting,
so he was very aware of the suffering of
the world and he really felt like this
was very morally questionable for me to
do.
I was very naturally taken aback by
that,
but I had done a lot of thinking about
it because it is something that you
worry about when you're thinking about
happiness is.
I did say to myself,
is this very selfish?
Is it morally inappropriate to be
thinking about happiness when there's so
much suffering in the world?
I'd been thinking about it sort of,
but it wasn't until he really gave me
that withering look of disgust that I
really focused on how did I.
What did I think about the pursuit of
happiness?
Did I feel like this was laudable and
what I found is that in my experience,
people who are happy in their own lives,
they have the emotional wherewithal to
turn outward and to think about the pain
of the world and they're more able to
intervene effectively because we more
unhappy.
We tend to be isolated and defensive and
preoccupied with our own problems,
and so it's not the case that happiness
makes people complacent or self
satisfied or preoccupied with their own
pleasure.
In fact,
happiness kind of energizes people to
turn outward.
Professor Todd Kashdan focusing on
happiness,
trying to improve people's happiness,
writing books about happiness.
This is a big money making industry and
while I'm critical of it,
I recognize that this opens the doors
for people to think about how they can
improve their lives,
their relationships,
and the way that they're operating in
this world which might be sub optimal.
And so,
uh,
Gretchen Rubin,
who's a good friend of mine,
she's dealing with how to create optimal
conditions for human beings.
And she's focusing on multiple pathways
of getting there.
She's focusing on multiple ways of
setting goals,
meeting your goals,
deriving benefits just from devoting
effort,
much less whether you even achieve your
goals,
and I think this.
It's important to get the dialogue going
and so it ends up being that happiness
is the gateway for having people think
about ways that they can intentionally
improve their own lives and lives of
other people.
It's a great thing,
but what ends up happening is this
nebulous wastebasket term where
happiness is pretty much everything
that's good in life.
If we focus on happiness as a synonym
for the good life or a synonym for a
well lived life,
we miss out on so many facets,
so many nuances of what it means to be
human and it beat full capacity.
Creativity,
spirituality,
meaning and purpose in light,
compassion,
self compassion,
a sense of accomplishment,
a sense of belonging,
a sense of what these things are not
synonymous with happiness and there are
plenty of happy people that are not
creative,
that are not spiritual,
that are not mindful,
and so using a wastebasket term to
capture all of the beauties and
complexities of human behavior is
extremely problematic and it trivializes
just how amazing and how complicated it
is to navigate our social world.
I've said that some people will tell you
that the purpose of life is to be happy
and those people are idiots and was a
bit of a rough statement,
but I what I meant by that.
It was actually inspired by a statement
by Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn who was the
great critic of the Soviet prison system
and he commented that happiness is
something that's done in by the first
harsh blow.
That reality deals you and and,
and I believe this to be the case there.
There are many circumstances in life
where happiness is not only the wrong
response,
but also where the expectation of
happiness as a response,
we'll put you,
the person attempting to be happy in
absolutely the wrong psychological state
to be prepared for what must be done.
People are built so to speak,
to experience a very wide range of
motivational and emotional states that
only bear a tenuous relationship to one
another,
and the reason for that is that the
environment that human beings inhabit is
so complex that are adaptations depends
on a variety of very finally
differentiated responses and so there is
a time to be compassionate and there's a
time to be aggressive and there's a time
to be in pain and there's a time to be
anxious and there's a time to be joyous
and a time to be satisfied,
and the healthy and well adapted person
has a very wide range of finally
differentiated response which cannot be
boiled down to a single dimension.
Say happiness versus unhappiness.
A life is not that simple,
and if it was,
we'd only have one system
happiness.
All it is is it's a barometer.
It's Dr Phil,
one-on-one,
Dr Phil always asked,
how are things working for you?
And if you say things are working well,
that's pretty.
That's pretty much what we mean by
happiness.
Happiness does not propel us forward,
so it's very weird to meet this,
the objective of your life and what I
mean by that is while I love being a
father,
I can.
I will tell you point blank with my wife
listening,
that it has not improved my happiness,
meaning and purpose in life through the
roof.
Happiness.
I was much happier as a 30 year old
having a lot of time with friends and a
lot of time to travel and a lot of time
to basically do whatever the hell that I
wanted to.
So in terms of my happiness,
it's detracted from it.
Are there moments of the most profound
pleasure of the most profound
spirituality that I would die for these
sacred vessels that I have in my life?
Absolutely,
but that's not happiness,
that's spirituality to me is striving
for the sacred and the sacred is things
that you would be willing to die for.
What I die for a sense of satisfaction
in my life.
No,
what would I be willing to take the
bullet over my kids?
Absolutely
making happiness.
The focal point of your life trivializes
your experiences because in order to
regard anything as truly important,
you also have to regard it's loss as
truly meaningful,
and that means that to open yourself up
to experiences of deep meaning also
simultaneously means that you have to
open yourself up to the possibility of
deep hurt and sorrow
and you do that anytime,
for example,
that you make a relationship profound.
You put your emotions on the line and
that has to be real or the relationship
can be real and to hope that that sort
of risk could be obliterated by the
indulgence in a simplistic form of
happiness is to shrink.
I think empowered is from the demands
that real human existence place on
people.
This is ideas in Canada on CBC radio,
one across North America on Sirius
Satellite Radio,
Channel One 59 and around the world on
CBC dot Ca.
I'm Paul Kennedy.
You're listening to CBC,
producer Frank Faux say no to happiness.
The renowned psychiatrist and
concentration camp survivor Viktor
Frankl wrote what man actually needs is
not attention list state,
but rather the striving and struggling
for a worthwhile goal of freely chosen
task.
There is much wisdom in the words of
Nietzsche.
He who has a why to live for can bear
almost anyhow.
We now return to frank's,
say no to happiness
at every moment.
We're surrounded by what we know and can
understand,
but outside of that,
we're surrounded by all the things that
we do not know and cannot understand and
that can manifest themselves at any
moment.
So we're like small islands of tentative
certainty in a massive sea of
uncertainty and ignorance.
That's our existential condition.
It's really our environment.
Even from a scientific perspective.
It's the environment that we've emerged
into and have adapted to and we have to
take that into account when we deal with
our lives because that's the truest
nature of our life.
It's ordering the midst of the infinite
chaos.
The human problem is how to make sense
out of the constant interplay between
that tentative order,
right?
Not Infinite chaos.
Jordan Peterson is a professor of
psychology at the University of Toronto.
He is also the author of maps of
meaning,
the architecture of belief.
His book explores how religious and
mythological stories shed light on our
existential predicament and in turn can
provide a sense of meaning and purpose.
In the Old Testament in genesis,
it's one of the most profound ideas ever
expressed.
The Old Testament,
God in genesis generates order out of
chaos and upon doing so,
he states,
man and woman are made in my image.
What does he mean by that?
Well,
he dignifies the human soul with that
statement,
but the attribution of dignity is based
on a psychological and an ontological
reality,
and that reality is that what the
individual consciousness confronts his
equivalent in some sense to the chaos
that God originally turned into order at
the beginning of time.
In that what you confront moment to
moment is the potential of being.
That's what consciousness does.
It takes unformed potential and makes it
manifest and each human being has the
choice about which direction that
potential will manifest itself in,
but not about whether or not that
manifestation will take place because it
takes place no matter what and that's
why the moral obligation of existence is
incumbent on our being.
Existence implies coexistence to be is
to be involved with the life of others.
We delude ourselves if we think that
we're simply innocent bystanders and
life being is never neutral.
What we do matters.
You can be a creator of things positive
or you can be a creator of things
negative or you can be a creator who
abdicated their responsibility,
but in all three situations,
you are participating in the process
that turns chaos into order and there is
no escaping that.
When the high school kids,
the chart up columbine wrote about their
philosophy and the most telling aspect
of their philosophy was their judgment
of existence state and they did.
You can read this on the net.
Their conclusion at the great age of 19
was that the tragedy of existence was
such that being itself was corrupt.
That because people suffered and because
of the world was a dangerous and
terrible place.
That being itself should be eradicated
and this is a very common judgment,
is far more common than people think,
and once you forego the luxury of
deciding in a sense to hell with
everything that that everything is so
corrupt that it's unredeemable.
Once you forego that luxury,
then it becomes incumbent on you to try
to work for the betterment of being in
that requires faith and the reason it
requires faith is because a,
you don't know if ben can be bettered
and B,
you don't know if you're the creature to
do it,
but the peculiar thing is is that you
will never find out if being can be
bettered or if you're the creature to do
it until you assume that it can be
bettered and you assume that you are the
creature to do it.
Critics of religious thinking believed
that what faith means is the willingness
to suspend rational judgment and swallow
any old thing.
No matter how absurd,
and that's not what faith means at all.
What faith means is the willingness to
put yourself on the line in pursuit of
those things that you find deeply
meaningful and that's why so many great
philosophers such as Soren kierkegaard
emphasize above all the role that faith
plays.
I'm a clinical psychologist.
I have an active practice,
so I have 20 clients and I see them
weekly and I'm a professor of psychology
at the University of Toronto,
and so it might be surprising that I use
religious language,
but it's not surprising because as soon
as you start to talk about the deepest
meanings of life,
the language that is most appropriate is
immediately religious and the reason for
that is that religion is precisely that
element of human existence that deals
with the most profound elements of human
being.
I believe that the reason for this is
this,
in some sense,
human existence is so contradictory that
it's in in a manner technically
impossible.
We're limited creatures and we face
unlimited catastrophe in in everything
we know will disappear and everyone we
love will die,
and so that makes existence.
Human existence in a sense existentially
impossible,
but the religious impulse combats that.
In a sense,
because the religious impulse opens up
to the human being the possibility that
there is sufficient absolute within to
serve as an antidote to the absolute
without and the notion that it's
necessary to have an individual
relationship with the absolute,
with God,
for example,
is a statement of the fact that we are
in fact adapted to the nature of reality
and if we draw on everything that is
within ourselves without fear,
then we can develop the sorts of
personalities that are powerful enough
to confront the horrible absolute and to
consider that justifiable and
worthwhile.
I want to put it in a good word coming
from the Jewish tradition,
a good word for happiness.
It's,
it's.
It's striking to me that the very first
word in the first verse of the First
Chapter of the Book of Psalms is a word
that is probably best translated as
happy.
So it says in Psalms,
happy is the one who does not stand in
the way of the wicked or walk with
sinners or sit in the company of
mockers,
but whose delight is in the law of the
Lord in God's law.
Does he meditate day and night?
Happiness is a,
I think a not a bad thing.
It's certainly better than its opposite,
but,
but clearly it is inadequate as a goal
for our lives.
If that's all that we can inspire to
then alive,
do become trivial,
then they become insignificant.
The happiest creature in the world I
think is a lizard sitting in the sun,
and if all we want to be or lizards
sitting in the sun,
it won't work for us because we have an
awareness that lizards don't have.
We have an awareness that there is
something greater than ourselves,
greater than our material,
corporeal being that there is the
infinite.
Dan Polish is the author of talking
about God,
exploring the meaning of religious life
with character,
guard,
boober,
Tillich and Heschel in his book,
Polish explorers.
How each of these thinkers understand
the human encounter with the infinite.
The Danish Christian philosopher Soren
Kierkegaard coined the term angst or
anxiety to describe our experience as
limited being overwhelmed by the
infinite.
Paul Tillich,
a Christian theologian talked about the
courage to be in the face of our
existential predicament.
The Jewish theologian Martin Buber
talked about the importance of holding
ourselves open to the unconditional
mystery that we encounter in every
sphere of our life.
Rabbi Abraham Joshua Heschel spoke of
knowing life has ultimate meaning.
Though we can never fully comprehend
that meaning only sense it.
All of them could be characterized is
existentialist thinkers,
by which I mean that they like other
existentialist recognize that as
Shakespeare said,
there's more in heaven and earth and
there is in your philosophy of ratios.
They don't focus on creating theories.
They know that the mind can go only so
far so they don't start with theory.
They start with a with human experience
it religiously.
That means that they are less interested
in talking about what God is a then
talking about how we human beings
respond to God rather than trying to
define that which they recognize
ultimately as beyond the capacity for
human beings to either define or even
understand and that unless we find a way
of living constructively with the
infinite are living in the infinite.
Unless we find the courage to have faith
in that which we cannot begin to
understand or begin to articulate a,
then we're,
then we're going to suffer what
kierkegaard called angst.
We're going to suffer that anxiety.
Character guard by all accounts was not
a happy fellow.
He suffered a major romantic
disappointment as a young man and
eventually retreated into a solitary
life of study and writing when it came
to achieving happiness in this life.
He didn't believe it was possible.
The best we can do is aspire to diminish
the anx that defines human existence.
As for the other three,
the who lived in the 20th century,
that,
that I've written about Heschel,
Uber,
Tillich,
all three of them knew a great deal of
suffering in their lives so that the
idea of happiness being something
paramount,
I think would look ridiculous to them,
or three of them were forced to leave
Germany and Europe.
Uh,
when it fell under Nazi domination.
Heschel of course,
came to the United States before the
full horrors of the Nazi reality acted
itself out in Europe.
He was living in Cincinnati,
Ohio when he got word that his whole
family had been exterminated.
My guess is that anybody who's life is
shaped as his wife's by that experience
would really not take the notion of
happiness is the goal of life very
seriously.
And in this book on the Prophets,
he says,
quote,
the world is dark and human agony is
excruciating.
This is not the,
uh,
the writings of somebody who could
understand human life in terms of what
we're calling happiness here.
Yeah.
It's something strange that I've
observed with my students is that when I
state the proposition to them clearly
that life is suffering and that the
purpose of life is not happiness.
They actually experienced that as a
great relief.
And the reason I believe that they
experienced it as a great relief is they
already know it.
You know,
even if they wouldn't necessarily
articulate that their experience has
taught them that life is complex and
tragic and difficult.
And the problem with the public
portrayal of the ideal state of
humanness as happiness is that it makes
all of these people,
these young people feel ashamed of their
own suffering.
They feel that if they're suffering and
if they find their life tragic in its
essence,
that that means that there's something
wrong with them and instantly that makes
it impossible for them to communicate
anything real about their own tragedy.
One of the great spiritual geniuses of
all humanity was the Buddha and the
Buddha came to an understanding that,
that he can talk about human life in
terms of four noble truths.
And the first of the noble truths is
that all of life is Duco,
which we,
which we can translate as suffering.
Uh,
the Buddhist teaching.
I said the essence of the human
experience is to suffer that suffering
is not some unfortunate thing that
disrupts an otherwise perfect existence
or that suffering is a,
you know,
an accident that may be false on people.
The Buddhist teaching that suffering is
at the heart of being a human.
And so it appears to me that the price
we pay for being is suffering.
And then the issue there,
and I believe that this is what the
greater religious traditions of the
world have been attempting to elucidate,
is that the purpose of life given that
is to identify and and follow a mode of
being that makes life justifiable,
even given the radical necessity of
suffering.
If you're constantly in a state of
placidity satisfaction and happiness,
then nothing is going to affect you
deeply enough,
not your own suffering and the suffering
of other people.
Not Injustice,
not knocked the horrors of the world.
Nothing is going to affect you deeply
enough so that you'll become deep and
life without depth is by definition
shallow and meaningless,
and there's a problem that's associated
with that because life is tragic and
because life involves suffering.
If your philosophy is shallow and
meaningless,
when you suffer,
you'll become resentful and hostile and
self critical and then you'll become
cruel and destructive.
And so not only is there a necessity for
your own mental health too,
rightly confront the deepest questions
of life,
but if you don't,
then you remain a danger to yourself.
And maybe more importantly to others,
the suffering that we experience is
something that we can use.
There's the well known image of the
grain of sand that finds its way into
the shell of an oyster and out of that
discomfort,
the oyster fashions,
the Pearl,
the ox,
the kierkegaard talks about can become
the inspiration of for us to live in
ways that transcend simple selfishness,
simple egocentricity simple focusing on
ourselves.
Reinhold Niebuhr,
who was actually a very close friend of
Heschel,
said that life has no meaning except in
terms of responsibility.
I'm sure how she would shake his head.
Absolutely.
One of Heschel's earliest books is
called the image of God in this world.
Humanity.
Human beings are God's image in this
world.
Our goal in life is very clear to be in
this world where we would want God to be
in this world
for us through our actions and our
behaviors and our engagements to
manifest God in the world,
to be radically discontent with the
things that exist in this world,
social evils that we see around us.
Do what we can to write them
because we are God's own self.
Is it work in this world
which actually wouldn't say means where
we finally become the most human.
I've gotten very interested in the
psychology of morality because we often
push it aside to just religious
teachings,
religious ideas,
and when we're making moral decisions on
a daily basis and it makes me think of
exemplars of people that have profound
meaning and purpose in life,
but are probably average to below
average on happiness and Martin Luther
King happens to be a real great example
of this.
Todd Cashton is associate professor of
psychology at George Mason University in
Virginia.
He is the author of designing positive
psychology,
a book on the science of wellbeing.
Professor cashton regularly gives talks
and workshops on how to live a
worthwhile and meaningful life.
This is someone in context who had
extreme righteous indignation.
This is a.
This is just a manifestation of anger of
the mistreatment of other of other
fellow human beings on the lack of
equality and fairness.
These are fundamental moral principles
and his life was devoted to this.
If you're talking about pursuing goals
that are outside the parameters of
happiness,
look to Martin Luther King,
the idea of absorbing the blues,
the hatred,
the prejudice,
the discrimination for other people to
make a point that these,
these behaviors are not indicative of
what a good society is built on,
and Martin Luther King is not the only
person.
He just happens to be a public exemplar.
You have people in schools right here in
DC where I'm sitting right now who are
devoting themselves in inner city kids.
You've got teachers that are creating a
safe space for them,
a place where they can actually learn
and grow and become a moral outstanding
citizen.
We're talking about people that are
taking time away from their own
happiness to do something that really
matters and but lead to a sense of
morality,
meaning and purpose in life that just
don't fit on the same spectrum.
Now,
there are multiple pathways to living a
good life and I think a better approach
than having happiness as the ultimate
end point is to do things you care
about.
We're not talking about happiness.
We're talking about engagement.
We're talking about meaningful pursuits.
Nothing can drive you to find the
deepest meanings of life without first
realizing the absolute fragility of life
because there's nothing that's
sufficiently terrifying as realization
of that absolute fragility and it's
necessary to be profoundly terrified
before you can be motivated to seek out
those things that are of the highest
value as a consequence of considering
these ideas for many years and
especially considering the role that
evil has played,
say in the 20th century and also the
role that suffering plays in life.
I've asked myself deeply what the
purpose of life might be and it seems to
me that life requires virtue and so then
you might ask,
well,
what do I mean by virtue?
And what I mean by virtue is following
whatever it is in your life that
manifests itself to you as meaningful
and right,
and there's Cota sales to that.
For example,
in order to determine clearly what's
meaningful in right,
you have to stop light because if you
lie to yourself or you lie to other
people,
you blind yourself and then the things
that might appear to you as meaningful
or no longer trustworthy because you're
using an instrument that you voluntarily
damaged to perceive reality and that
will lead you astray and virtue requires
while requires humility because you have
to stop thinking that you know,
and so humility and honesty are absolute
preconditions.
Courage as well as necessary because
you'll have to learn to come to terms
with your own capacity for anxiety and
dread and aggression and and even your
capacity for welfare,
terrible acts,
and to continually set yourself right is
to walk down the path I believe of moral
virtue.
I would contrast the difference between
having happiness as a desirable thing,
which it's incredibly desirable to be
happy,
but what I like to talk about is
thinking about this as a compass.
Provide a navigator of which direction
to go into.
It doesn't tell them what direction it
says,
here's the direction that you're facing.
If happiness is your compass to navigate
through the complexities and ambiguities
of life,
it means when something is negative or
problematic,
that's the wrong direction to move into.
When it's your values become your
compass,
it's very different.
Let me give you example,
so one of my fundamental values,
I have twin four year old girls,
is to try to be a good father and
instill good values in them and try to
cultivate their strikes and so when I'm
faced with conflicts,
which we all are faced with,
I love writing.
I love doing science.
I loved teaching and I'm in the middle
of a great writing session.
Eight hours.
I'm in flow of the words were just
spilling out of my brain onto the page
and I looked at the clock and I realize
it's almost time for their bedtime.
I've got a conflict here.
Do I continue with this incredible
writing session or do I make sure I've
seen my kids before?
I let you go to sleep,
read them a story,
tuck them in,
show them some affection,
and maybe come back to this.
Am I writing?
Might not be as good afterwards.
Knowing that my values are to trying to
be a good father and instill values in
them helps me with the decision and it
helps them decide,
you know what?
I'm going to go home,
spend some time my children come back to
my work.
If happiness is my objective,
it leaves me in a much bigger quandary
of all of these conflicts of what do I
do with the limited amount of time and
energy I have in any given day and all
of these competing things that are
fighting for my attention,
meaning and purpose in life and values
is a very stable compass.
This is a way to create a life,
to feel good about who we are,
to have an understanding of what type of
person we want to be and try to close
the gap between what we do and what we
strive to become.
I want to make my personal signature on
my work so that I leave the world a
little bit of a better place,
deeply embedded again in western
religious thinking.
That reality is in some sense incomplete
unfinished and the name of the human
being is to complete it.
To perfect it,
to finish it and see the idea that
reality is in some sense unfinished and
hence it's tragic in an incomplete
manner and that the role of the human
being is in some sense to participate in
its perfection is a concept that is so
profound that it makes happiness as a
concept design to encapsulate the
meaning of life so shallow that it
instantly becomes virtually negligible.
We have a hypothesis here that the
purpose of conscious being is for those
beings who are conscious to transcend
their mortar limitations and to work for
the perfection of all that exists as a
goal that justifies suffering.
That's unbeatable.
I think because what it does is broaden
and deepen your life in a manner that
you might compare to the difference
between elevator music and a Beethoven
symphony.
It's not that the symphony is in any
sense happier than the Muzak and in fact
quite the contrary,
but it's deeper and more profound
enricher and incorporates more and
justifies itself more.
And that's the right metaphor for life.
Not Happiness,
but but depth and and and differentiated
quality and profundity to match the
profundity of the necessity of
suffering.
Today on ideas.
Say No to happiness by CBC producer
Frank Fall.
You heard interviews with Gretchen
Rubin,
author of the happiness project,
Jordan Peterson,
professor of psychology at the
University of Toronto,
Dan Polish,
author of talking about God,
explaining the meaning of religious life
with Kierkegaard,
Uber,
Tillich and pestle.
And Todd Cashton,
associate professor of psychology at
George Mason University in Virginia.
Our associate producer is lose
knowledge,
technical production by date field.
To find out about upcoming ideas,
programs,
and podcasts,
sign up for our weekly online
newsletter.
Just go to our website at CBC.ca/ideas
and follow the links.
The executive producer ideas is Bernie.
Look then dime Paul Kennedy.
Stay tuned now for the hourly news on
CBC Radio One and on Sirius satellite
radio 1:59.
And.